[Music]
lori is in chicago hi laurie welcome to
the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i am going to court tomorrow for credit
card debt
a
the credit card original company sold it
to a debt
buyer
and now the lawyer is suing me
and i tried settling two times
and they really wouldn't go down very
much it's the original that is 8 500
and they went down as far as 59.85
i was just wondering if you had any
ideas of what i could do as far as
facing
a lawyer tomorrow or if i should still
try to call this company that's not
working with me they wanted me to make
payments and i know you're not for that
yeah i wouldn't do that it doesn't work
out well for you um the lump sum
settlement is the only way to go have
you got the money to settle tomorrow
no not no i don't have that much i tried
settling um i can give them 2300. how
much do you get
2 300. okay what was the original debt
uh
85.50 that was the original debt
not what they say you owe
i'm not sure how how that exactly works
how much did you borrow
how much was owed when you quit paying
it
well it went through another collection
agency was sold again so no no no that's
not what i'm asking i'm asking when you
quit paying the credit card
how much was owed
um
sorry years ago few of them um
nine
i believe it was nine thousand seven
hundred and sixty six dollars no i was
making perfect no it wouldn't have gone
down well i made i was making payments
to the original
uh oh
okay all right
well they probably as you've heard on
the show probably paid a nickel on the
dollar for it
right so they probably got five hundred
bucks in this dad
um can you get any more together than
2500
well i have some save for my um
my
taxes on my house
um i mean
i'm very limited
maybe 3 000. okay all right
or maybe if you used a little bit of
that tax money if you get rid of this
it's worth it okay if you go to 3 500 or
4 000 and you get rid of an eight or ten
thousand dollar debt it's going to be
worth it so here's what's going to
happen
all right when you go into court on a
debt this size you it's um very similar
this is not high drama
with matlock or some big high-powered
whatever you think of attorney on some
television show okay
this is more like going to traffic court
when you got a ticket that time
you ever done that
not that but i've done something else
okay you've gone to a court when it was
like a big yawn
and it was all like a conveyor belt and
it was automatic and nobody cared and
there was no drama and there was no
shaming and there was nothing legal it
was just boom clip clip clip you're out
of there
that's what this is going to be
i heard you once say
to um try to find the lawyer ahead of
time yes and to make a deal then in the
hall yeah
otherwise walk up in front of the judge
and tell the judge you've tried to make
a deal
and you know that this is a debt buyer
and you know that they paid a nickel on
the dollar for it approximately because
that's under industry standard and i'm
standing here offering this guy three
thousand dollars and we can't get him to
take it your honor
and he's gonna shame the attorney then
because you're gonna be the only human
that showed up on this whole thing this
guy's got 200 cases all of them are on
automatic smackdown
and no humans show up except old laurie
and there she stands
so you're going to be like the
entertainment for the morning
right
do they care about any of my
no
no
nothing they don't care about your story
they don't think they don't care if
you're pitiful they don't care yeah
that's fine it's just money okay it's
just very awkward very agnostic
there's no spirit to it there's no
morals to it it's just i want some money
and if you give me some money oh and i
don't like the money and then the you
tell the judge and here's the money and
the judge goes oh come on
it's going to sound like that it's going
to be like judge judy or something in
here right
okay you don't think that the lawyer
will or i mean the judge will say that
make payments he might
he might he might slap you with a
garnishment i don't know it's possible
but you don't have a lot of options here
your only option is settle it if you
can't settle it ask the judge to settle
it otherwise he's going he's going to
make you do something because he's going
to do that anyway if you don't show up
they're going to get a judgment and
they're going to begin to garnish you
yeah i'll show up okay but i'm just
saying if you don't show you
automatically lose but by the way you're
in the wrong so you're automatically
going to lose anyway
i know the only question is can you just
you know by by being a human and being
there do you influence the process and
get a settlement
but you got really no defense you owe
the debt you didn't pay it there's no
defense
how old is this dad
um
it was from um well these guys purchased
it in 2020. when did you know okay
the last time i paid so it's a few years
old
18 2018. okay and what was it originally
what kind of credit card
uh the name of the credit card was
capital one okay all right
yeah they'll sue you on ten thousand
bucks they usually won't screw with it
on under five because it's not worth
their legal hassle but the debt buyers
sometimes will screw with it if they buy
it under five
and so
yeah this is a pretty substantial
account most debt is under five thousand
dollars per card
but good old capital one what's in your
wallet lawsuits
apparently man
i haven't i haven't heard a lot of
situations where people are going to
court over the credit card debt it
doesn't happen very often it's usually
they just deal with the debt settlement
companies and they try to negotiate the
debt buyer will usually settle and again
folks they're buying these things at a
nickel on the dollar
um
and you know we did this oh yeah
christmas before last we paid off a
bunch of debt yeah we bought 10 million
dollars worth of debt
from um from
a lot of it was medical debt
and uh we we bought 10 million dollars
for a quarter on our for two and a half
percent paid 250 000 for it and we call
we had all of our uh eight our employees
get we gave them eight each there was
like um what uh there was like ten
thousand accounts roughly
and uh they each called and told people
for christmas that their debt was
forgiven so we bought ten million
dollars worth and forgave it
and it was our christmas present it's
what we did for christmas yeah we had
our products our favorite gift and it
was a blast but we bought that for 250
000 is 10 million a little north of 10
million so that's that's 25 cents on i
mean that's two and a half cents on the
dollar yeah we bought the whole book
there's the proof i mean now that was
old medical debt which is that by the
way it's usually cheaper to buy yeah
than on credit cards there was some car
loans in there too i remember calling
someone and saying we paid off that yeah
we got a few credit cards in there i
think we got i think we probably got i
don't know a couple hundred credit cards
in there but most of it was medical
but so you you can buy debt for a nickel
on the dollar and then go try to collect
it um anything they make over that is
profit yeah we didn't collect it we just
sent them all letters and a lot of them
thought we were scamming them oh yeah no
one believed me when i called they said
what i didn't ask you to do that's so
fun we got some great videos there were
some inspiring ones too a lot of
somebody just broke down and cried yeah
it was sweet but some people were just
angry with me yeah why are you calling
me i'm busy okay sorry sir have a good
day just calling to tell you you don't
know the debt anymore what i didn't ask
you to do that are you welcome
to do that who are you what are you the
grinch it's christmas
oh my gosh too funny it's a blast so
yeah that's the truth and so you can you
can buy debt like that and if you want
to write big checks anyway and so
that's kind of proof that what we're
saying is true that you can buy it for a
nickel on there which is why they're
probably going to nickel and the dollar
on it and this is a good old citibank at
your service
just think of that next time you see one
of those stupid butt commercials of
theirs